digamos que tenemos dos depósitos de
calor ok
digamos que tenemos uno aquí que es
caliente ok que está a una temperatura
de h y que tengo aquí mi máquina aunque
que va a ser una máquina de carnot
porque hemos aprendido que no hay mejor
máquina que las de carne ok es la más
eficiente tenemos una máquina de carnota
y opera en ciertas diferencias de calor
ok y toma calor de este cuerpo caliente
ok
toma ese calor que uno realiza cierto
trabajo
ok digamos un trabajo w el trabajo es
algo bueno ok y después
se le quita calor a la máquina hacia una
hacia un cuerpo frío ok le quitamos q2 y
le libera calor a cierto cuerpo frío que
está a una temperatura tc
ahora ya he hecho múltiples
insinuaciones en los vídeos anteriores
de que esta es la máquina más eficiente
que podríamos que podríamos crear entre
dos depósitos de calor uno th que es
caliente y otro tc que es frío ahora
podríamos podrían venir decir no no no
no no mira yo conozco un amigo que ha
inventado una nueva máquina que es más
eficiente que esta máquina entre estas
dos mismas témperas si entre estas dos
mismas temperaturas y va así y dibujas
el mismo diagrama de la máquina de tu
amigo aunque diga y tú dices bueno
déjenme hacer esto claro para que quede
claro que son los los mismos depósitos
de calor de hecho debería dibujar bueno
vamos a dejarlo así ok entonces vamos a
dejar los mismos depósitos de calor
entonces estamos todo esta temperatura
th y el de acá abajo a tc ok
muy bien así que tu amigo tiene una
supuesta máquina vamos a llamarle la
súper máquina
es la súper máquina de tu amigo afirma
que nos va a demostrar porque su máquina
este es la mejor y yo les voy a decir
aquí porque no puede existir porque
desafiar a la segunda ley de la
termodinámica ok supongamos que entonces
toma un calor q no ok pero que produce
más trabajo que tu máquina de carnota
digamos w más o una proporción del to w
ok no quiero irme muy algebraico pero
digamos que produce w más otra fracción
que lo podemos escribir con wv por uno
más x donde x es un número positivo ok
lo que sea que sea x no ok entonces el
resto de la energía como baja hacia el
cuerpo frío bueno como se queda es q no
menos el trabajo entonces con uno menos
w por uno más x
y solo para ser claro q dos de aquí lo
podría escribir como q 1 - w muy bien
así que miremos eso y tú puedes decirme
y de venir y decirme no no no esto de
esto esto está mejor no porque sí sí yo
pensemos si esto fuera cierto podríamos
resolver todos los problemas de energía
del mundo tendríamos una máquina de
movimiento perpetuo y desafiar y amos
todas las leyes que conocemos hasta
ahora pero podría partir de diseñar una
máquina de carbón reversible ok así que
mi máquina carnot revertida podría verse
de esta forma
digamos la máquina canon revertida y va
a ser la misma cosa de esta de la
izquierda pero al revés ok y en vez de
producir este 1 - w vamos a producir
digamos vamos va a bajar el calor hacia
te va a subir perdón en este caso la
temperatura de tc a la máquina
1 - w y dijimos que podíamos
multiplicarlo por cualquier factor
entonces digamos que sube a la máquina y
y multipliquemos vamos a diseñar esta
máquina que además está x 1 + x ok
entonces hicimos una máquina de carnota
revertida pero con un factor de escala y
multiplicando un poco ok entonces si
multiplicamos de esa forma requiere que
introduzca un trabajo un trabajo igual a
quien a w x 1 x ok digo sí sí sí en la
original podíamos producir w aquí
entraría w pero ya estamos multiplicando
por un factor y entonces vamos a liberar
calor hacia el cuerpo caliente uno por
uno más x entonces esencialmente es la
primera máquina revertida y todo
multiplicando x 1 + x ok entonces hay
trabajo que necesita realizarse a la
máquina para que esto suceda entonces si
tú vienes y dices
esto parece parece bastante agradable
porque mi máquina mi amigo tiene una
máquina super una super máquina que el
trabajo que produce es el mismo que
utiliza esta máquina de carne otra
vertida ok simplemente tanto como
produce la súper máquina es como podemos
lo que necesita nuestra máquina de
carnot reversible así que vamos a vamos
a moverlo de esta forma okay vámonos de
este lado
creo que es la mejor forma de hacerlo y
que estar seguros de que entendemos que
esto es el mismo depósito de calor son
las mismas temperaturas todo el tiempo
ok el de arriba es mi fuente de de un
cuerpo caliente y el de abajo es frío
así que si juntamos ambas máquinas
déjenme ponerlo con un nuevo color creo
que esto se está volviendo monótono y
hoy no
hay poquitos colores eso con este así
que sí combinó todos esto estas dos
máquinas esencialmente ambas van a estar
operando a la par estamos entonces vamos
a llamar a esta la máquina la súper
máquina más la máquina de carnota
revertida así que qué ocurre ahora cuál
es el calor neto que se está tomando de
la máquina aunque yo que sé que se
introduce ok por ejemplo por abajo del
cuerpo frío tenemos 1 - w x 1x y aquí
tenemos 1 - w x 1x en esta dirección así
que quiero que sea claro cuál es el
álgebra aquí tenemos que 1 x 1 x x que
diga menos w x 1 x
ok ahora si comparamos estos dos el de
la derecha es mucho más grande porque
estos dos términos son iguales y con uno
por uno más x es mayor que uno ok es muy
es grande por un factor x porque uno ok
si combinamos estos dos ok
además como son movimientos en
direcciones contrarias en realidad
tenemos que tomar la diferencia para ver
cuál es el calor neto que se se
introduce o sale ok entonces como este
de la derecha es más grande entonces en
realidad va a haber un calor que pasa
del cuerpo frío a la máquina ok ya que
es más grande el de la máquina de carnal
reversible entonces
1 - w x 1 x es el de la súper máquina si
restamos estos dos términos estos se
cancelan y simplemente me queda que
bueno este primer término es q no más x
por q 11 por x y entonces estos conos se
cancelan y al final lo que sube es q no
por equis
1 por x muy bien muy bien ahora qué tal
es el trabajo que se realiza bueno lo
mismo que entra es lo mismo o más bien
lo mismo que saca la supermáquina es lo
mismo que necesita la máquina de carnal
revertida así que el trabajo neto pues
no hubo vamos a ver qué pasa con esto
ok vamos a ver cuál es la cantidad de
calor que sale de la máquina ok entonces
el de la derecha claramente es un número
más grande que el de la izquierda porque
con uno por uno más x es mayor que con
uno fíjense que con uno más que uno x es
justamente esto de aquí ok con uno por
uno más equis y si le restamos con uno
del lado izquierdo cancelamos los conos
y me queda que sube q 1 x
así que qué está ocurriendo aquí fíjate
tengo no no hay una energía externa o
trabajo que le está generando al trabajo
simplemente está tomando calor de un
cuerpo frío ok lo está moviendo a la
máquina y después calienta un cuerpo
caliente y esto lo hace indefinidamente
porque no necesita ni trabajo ni produce
trabajo entonces si lo piensas de esta
forma podría calentar mi casa con hielo
si tuviera una máquina de esta forma o
que yo podría crear vapor desde algunas
cosas de un algo frío arbitrario esto va
en contra de la segunda ley de la
termodinámica la la entropía neta en
este mundo está bajando y por qué está
aquí que está ocurriendo aquí esto
simplemente es una transferencia directa
de calor de un frío a un caliente que
está pasando en la entropía neta el
cambio la entropía del universo bueno el
cuerpo caliente está ganando calor así
que es uno
1x sobre sobre la temperatura del cuerpo
caliente que esté h y el cuerpo frío
está perdiendo calor entonces es menos
que 1 x / tc ahora tc es un número más
pequeño que th por lo tanto el de la
derecha es mucho más grande que el de la
izquierda si 1 x / tc es mayor que 1 x /
th por lo tanto es menor que cero y eso
rompe la segunda ley de la termodinámica
ok todo esto es independiente del
sistema y la entropía está encogiéndose
podríamos a partir de esta escala x que
decimos que existe en nuestra super
máquina que es mejor si alguien dice o
afirma que tiene una máquina más
eficiente que la podemos acoplar con una
máquina de carnota divertida y crear
esta máquina perpetua esta máquina
perpetua de refrigeración ok que es que
es que rompe la segunda ley de la
termodinámica porque el cambio de la
entropía es negativa así que es algo que
no puede realizarse en nuestro mundo
especialmente si creemos en la segunda
ley de la termodinámica así que la
máquina más eficiente es la máquina de
carnota donde su eficiencia está
descrita por 11 - tc sobre t h ok si
tenemos dos temperaturas 22 depósitos ok
uno digamos está a 500 grados kelvin y
el frío está a 300 grados kelvin
entonces tengo una máquina que toma
calor del de arriba lo empuja al de
abajo y realiza un trabajo la máquina
más eficiente que podría hacer sin
fricción por supuesto con mayor
eficiencia
es la de carne y sería 1 - 300 entre 500
que es uno menos tres quintos que es dos
quintos y dos quintos de 0.4 que es el
40 por ciento de eficiencia ok
así que si alguien te dice que han hecho
una máquina que opera entre un depósito
de 500 grados kelvin y uno de 300 grados
que él viene y te dice nada tengo un 41
por ciento de eficiencia bueno te está
mintiendo definitivamente de cualquier
forma espero que hayas encontrado esto
muy interesante nos vemos en el próximo